if i was five years old you were trying
to explain this to me is there ways to
try to sneak up to this
to what this unified world of
mathematics looks like you said number
theory he said geometry
words like topology
what does this universe begin to look
like are these what should we imagine in
our mind is it a
a three-dimensional surface
and we're trying to say something about
it
is it uh triangles and squares and cubes
like what what are we supposed to
imagine our minds is this natural number
what what's a good thing to try to
for people that
don't know any of these tools except
maybe some basic calculus and geometry
from high school that they should keep
in their minds
as to the unified world of mathematics
that also
allows us to explore the unified world
of physics
i mean what i
find kind of remarkable about this is
the way in which
these we've discovered these ideas but
they're they're actually quite alien to
our
everyday understanding you know we grow
up in this three spatial dimensional
world and we have
intimate understanding of certain kinds
of geometry and certain kinds of things
but um
these things that we've discovered in
both math and physics are
that they're not at all
close have any obvious connection to
kind of human everyday experience that
they're really quite different and i can
say some of my initial fascination with
this when i was
young and starting to learn about it was
actually
exactly this um
this kind of arcane nature of these
things it was a little bit like being
being told well there are these kind of
some semi-mystical experience that you
can acquire by a long study and whatever
except
that that it was actually true and
there's actually evidence that this
actually works
so you know i'm a little bit wary of
trying to give people
that kind of thing because i think it's
mostly misleading but one thing to say
is that you know that geometry is a
large
part of it and um
maybe one interesting thing to say very
that's about more recent some of the
most recent ideas is that it um when we
think about the geometry of our space
and time it's kind of three spatial and
one
time dimension it's a um
physics is in some sense about
something as kind of four dimensional in
a way and that a really interesting
thing about um some of the recent
developments and number theory have been
to realize that the um
these ideas that we were looking at you
know naturally fit into a context where
your your theory is for is kind of four
dimensional
so
so so john i mean geometry is a big part
of this and we know a lot and feel a lot
about you know two one two three
dimensional geometry so wait a minute so
we can at least rely
on the four dimensions
of space and time and say that we can
get pretty far by working that in those
four dimensions i thought you were going
to scare me that we're gonna have to go
to many many many many more dimensions
than that
my point of view which is which goes
against a lot of these ideas about
unification is that no this is really
everything we do we know about really is
about four dimensions that um
and and that you can actually understand
a lot of these structures that we've
been seeing in fundamental physics and
in
in number theory just in terms of
four dimensions that it's kind of it's
in some sense i would claim
has been a really um
has been kind of a mistake that
physicists have made and
for decades and decades to try to
to try to go to higher dimensions to try
to formulate a theory in higher
dimensions and then then you're stuck
with
the problem how do you get rid of all
these extra dimensions that you've
created and
because because we only ever see
anything in four dimensions that kind of
thing leads us astray you think so so
creating all these extra dimensions just
to get to give yourself extra degrees of
freedom
yeah it's not i mean isn't that the
process of mathematics is to create
all these trajectories for yourself but
eventually you have to end up at the uh
like a final place but it's okay to
it's okay to sort of um
create abstract objects on your path to
uh proving something
yeah so yeah certainly but and from from
mathematicians point of view
i mean
the kinds of mathematicians also are
very different than physicists and that
we like to develop very general theories
we like to if we have an idea we want to
um see what's the greatest generality in
which you can talk about it so from the
point of view of most of the ways
geometry is formulated um
by mathematicians it really doesn't
matter it works in any dimension we can
do
one two three four any any number
there's no particular
for most of geometry there's no
particular special thing but for
but um
anyway but but what physicists have have
been trying to do over the years is try
to understand
these fundamental theories in a
geometrical way and it's very tempting
to kind of just start bringing in
extra dimensions and using them to
explain the structure but
it um
typically this this attempt kind of
founders because you just don't know
you end up not being able to explain why
we only see four
anyway
it is nice in the space of physics that
uh like if you look at from o's last
theorem it's much easier to prove that
there's no solution for n equals three
than it is for the general case
and and so i guess that's the nice
benefit of being a physicist is you
don't have to worry about the general
case because we live in a universe with
n equals
four in this case
yeah the physiophysicists are very
interested in
saying something about specific examples
and
i find that interesting even when i'm
trying to do things in mathematics and
i'm trying even teaching courses and
mathematics students i find that
i'm teaching them in a different way
than um most mathematicians because i'm
very often very focused on examples on
what's
what's kind of the crucial example that
shows how this um
this powerful new mathematical technique
how it works and why you would want to
to do it
and i'm less interested in kind of
you know proving a precise theorem about
exactly when it's going to work and when
it's not going to work do you think
about really simple examples like
both for teaching and when you
try to solve a difficult problem are you
do construct like the simplest possible
examples that captures the fundamentals
of the problem and try to solve it yeah
yeah exactly that's often
a really fruitful way to if you've got
some idea to you just to kind of try to
boil it down to what's the simplest
situation in which this kind of thing is
going to happen and then try to really
understand that and understand that and
that that is almost always a really good
way to get insight into do you work with
the paper and pen or like for example
for me
um
coming from the programming side if you
if i look at a model if i look at some
kind of mathematical object
i like to mess around with it sort of
numerically i just visualize different
parts of it visualize however i can so
most of the work is like with neural
networks for example as you try to play
with the simplest possible example and
just to build up intuition by
um you know
any kind of object has a bunch of
variables in it
you start to mess around with them in
different ways and visualize in
different ways to start to build
intuition
or do you go to einstein route and just
imagine
like
everything inside your mind and sort of
build like thought experiments and then
work purely on paper and pen
well the the problem with this kind of
stuff
i'm interested in is it you you rarely
can kind of
it's really something that is really
kind of
or even the simplest example
you know it can is you can kind of see
what's going on by looking at something
happening in three dimensions
there's there's generally the structures
involved are um
either they're more abstract or if you
try to kind of embed them in some kind
of space and where you could
um manipulate them in some kind of
geometrical way it's going to be a much
higher dimensional space so even simple
examples
the embedding them into
three-dimensional space you're losing a
lot yeah or but but to capture what
you're
what you're trying to understand about
them you have to go to
four or more dimensions so it starts to
get to be hard to
and you can
train yourself to try it as much as to
kind of
think about things in your mind and you
know i often use
pad and paper and often if i'm
in my office often use the blackboard
um and you are kind of drawing things
but they're really kind of more abstract
representations of how
things are supposed to fit together and
they're not really
unfortunately not just kind of really
living in three dimensions where you can
i was supposed to be sad or excited by
the fact that our human minds can't
fully comprehend the kind of mathematics
you're talking about i i mean
what do we make of that i mean to me
that makes me quite sad it makes me it
makes it seem like there's a giant
mystery out there that we'll never truly
get to experience
directly it is kind of sad you know how
difficult this is i mean i would put it
a different way that um
you know most questions that people have
about this kind of thing
you know you couldn't you can give them
a really a true answer and really
understand it but
the problem is is one more of um of time
it's like
yes you know i could explain to you how
this works but you have to be willing to
sit down with me and
you know work at this repeatedly for
you know for hours and days and weeks
and you you mean it's just going to take
that long for your mind to really wrap
itself around what's going on and um
and that so that does make things an
inaccessible which is uh
which is sad but it i get i mean it's
just kind of part of life that we all
have a limited amount of time and we
have to decide what we're gonna
what we're gonna spend our time doing
you